USA Today tweeted out some pretty  incredible videos of a top-down view you  might have seen this top-down view of  mountain climbers on the very top ridges  of the Alps it's insane footage take a  look at this just insane just absolutely  insane it's incredible I was watching  that we were all watching at the office  today and that got me wondering who the  hell is filming that there are thousands  of feet up in the air alone well guess  what I looked into it this longer  unedited video that was just released  yesterday I questioned all right I think  I got it  want me to airdrop this to you  the most outdated vision of God it's  like from a 1950s New Yorker cartoon